[Musique]
on est amis depuis combien de temps
depuis toujours
ne m'oublie jamais quoi qu'il arrive
tant que c'est des étoiles resteront
près l'une de l'autre toi et moi on sera
toujours ensemble
si ça se trouve il me cherche dehors
j'ai besoin que tu sois un peu plus
mature et que tu arrêtes de jouer comme
un comme un bébé j'étais enfermé et j'ai
besoin de retrouver Billy
il faut que tu m'aides il y a nous et il
y a la maladie si le temps est venu pour
moi j'aimerais pouvoir choisir comment
[Musique]
tu aimes de tout ton cœur
et pour qui tu serais prêt à déplacer
des montagnes
c'est moi le nouveau capitaine
[Musique]
pour savoir ce qu'on a dans notre petite
tête parfois il faut chercher ce qu'on a
dans le cœur
[Musique]
attendez vous seriez pas des ex petits
copains copines